for
I'm waiting for my wireless mic but I'm
going to get started while it's getting
here you sure in the right
class this is
valuation I before I get started how
many of you have taken a class in this
room before I'm not talking about that
first week whether do that little dance
of the first semester outside of that
for how many of you is this the first
class you've taken in this
room yeah this one this is the largest
classroom at NYU you know that
right it's funny because four kids have
all gone through college and each of
them had a chance to come to NYU with a
sweetener which is you know what it
is no tuition none of them picked that
choice I don't know why but with every
one of them I went through that little
dance you know when the one they show
you around the school and they lie all
the time about how every Professor is
around all the time and you know the
lies right they take you on the
orientation so I went along and acted
like any other parent which is stay
quiet because that's what kids want you
to do and they came in on top of this
this room because when you're out there
in front of the building you're actually
on top of the room and they said right
below this is the biggest
classroom at NYU but don't worry you
don't have to you'll never take classes
there almost put up my hand say no
that's not true it's the only room I've
ever taught in for the last 20 plus
years I don't like this
room it's got the Ambiance of Madison
Square Garden on a really bad Nick
day it's not a great room for
Acoustics why because you it's it's fine
if you all you don't want to do is hear
me as I said with the mic you'll be able
to hear me you know what this room was
never designed for the fact that you
might want to talk and other people in
the room might want to listen so I'm
going to tell your friend that I'm going
to try to do this when you ask me a
question I'm going to try to repeat the
question because otherwise you have no
idea it's like a conversation going on
this is what happens in Architects build
classrooms they think it's all about
oneway conversation so I'm going to try
right but let's talk about this class
before I do that let me get a sense of
where you're coming from any freshman in
this
class there one person I don't you don't
want to identify yourself that's fine
how many
sophomores
Juniors pict of the class
seniors so you want your grades in by
when before graduation so I I'll
remember that right
um I came to NYU
1986 seems like eons ago I just ran into
somebody whose mother was in my class
it's only a matter of time before run
into
grandmothers yeah I've been teaching it
a long time when I came to NYU in 1986
they gave me a class to
teach it's a class called security
analysis heard of this class it's a
class with a very long and Hy
tradition start in the 1950s at Columbia
University by a guy called Ben
Graham never heard of Ben Graham you've
heard of his most famous
student which is Warren Buffett it's a
class that was taught in Colombia class
which been taught a long time in 1986 I
come in this is the class they gave me
this is the class you're going to be
teaching I take one look at the class
said this is the most boring class ever
I'm not teaching it they should have
fired me on the spot for in
subordination but was a collection of
Topics by the time you got to
1986 it was four weeks on
stocks and three weeks on bonds and two
weeks on Futures and options and five
weeks on institutional detail like what
there was an entire session on listing
requirements for the New York Stock
Exchange teaching was so easy in the
days before
Wikipedia because today if I started
listing
there's no mic here I'll bring one down
okay today if I tried that you'd be
checking out Wikipedia while I teach
saying why is he listing these things I
can see
them so I went to the head of my
department said I don't want to teach
this class so good guy he said what
would you like to teach instead I said
I'd like to teach a valuation class just
remember what he said he said don't do
it there isn't enough stuff in Valu
to fill an entire
class what in 1986 he was absolutely
right there wasn't enough stuff in
valuation to fill a class there were no
books in valuation unless you wanted to
use Ben Graham security
analysis any of you know what year the
first edition of Ben grab security
analysis was
printed any
guesses
1934 what is happening in 1934 in the
US don't think too long you are coming
of the Great Depression if you read
security analysis it's imbued with risk
aversion and safety and who can blame
you right you came out of the Great
Depression what's your priority say
principle don't take risk I don't blame
Ben Graham for doing that by 1986 using
security
analysis would make any sense it's a
book for a different
age so I the head of my department is
right there wasn't enough stuff out
there to teach a class but I really
really really wanted to teach this class
and I discovered something very early in
my university life that I'm going to
pass on to you if you want to get
anything done at a university do it
subversively don't ask for
permission because if you ask for
permission you know what would happen a
committee will be formed
you guys have experiences what happens
when committees get formed they meet and
they meet they forget what they're
meeting about but they keep meeting
anyway because they're supposed to they
baby committees that they called
subcommittees and sub subcommittees it's
all very incestuous but about 35 years
later
they talk show thing right 35 years
later can you hear me yeah thank you
they'd come back to you and say you know
what you can teach the class but by then
I'd be too old to teach the
class so I said I'll teach you security
analysis
class I walked in closed the door
remember these were the days before
there were cameras in the classroom they
had no idea what I was doing in the
classroom I could be teaching cooking
for 15 weeks but if I gave everybody an
name nobody was going to complain
anyway and I taught my first valuation
class it was fall of 19
86 this is my 59th semester teaching
valuation I teach the same class with MB
exactly the same class to the last slide
starting Monday that'll be my
60th semester teach and I'm going to say
something about this class it's going to
encapsulate how I think about valuation
everything I know about valuation I've
learned in the course of teaching this
class I'm not walking in and read it up
somewhere else I learned in the course
of let me give you a few examples one
year into teaching this class was
October of 1987 I remember the day
October 19th it was a Monday I teach
only Monday Wednesdays I'm a very lazy
person I don't like to teach more than
two days a week so I finished teaching
my class at that time The Graduate
business school was downtown right next
to the American Stock
Exchange I finished my class was 10:30
in the morning I come back to my office
I look look out of my window and I see
that everybody from the American
Exchange floor is out there on the
street what happened fire alarm went
off you know what happened in markets
two markets on October 19th of
1987 it was a Black Monday but there
have been so many black
Mondays in history it was a particularly
Black Monday because on that day the S&P
500 dropped
22% in one day
convert that to today's numbers what
would a 22% drop in the Dow look like
right now be 8,000 Point drop in the Dow
if that happened you'd freak out before
you left this room because my job's gone
right people were freaking God they'd
never seen something like this in a
single day there a
Monday come back on Wednesday for the
next class guess what the first question
I'm asked in my classes how with your
valuation tools can you explain the
entire Market losing 22% of its value in
one day company you can explain a way
right bad things happen how does the
entire Market lose 22% of its value I'd
be lying if I said I knew the answer but
I have this very bad habit that my kids
point out which is when I don't know the
answer I try to my way to an
answer and I started that process and
I'm glad I did I started thinking about
what is it that causes Market
crisis and since 198 87 there have been
other crises which have allowed me
chances to revisit that question and I
hope and pray we won't have a market
crisis while we meet for the next four
and a half months but nothing is
guaranteed so everything I know about
Market crisis I started thinking about
on that day in October 19
1987 move forward a few years it is the
1990s and you see a new phenomenon in
public markets
of companies with lots of potential but
no business model yet going public I
mean those companies are always existed
but pre 1990s where did they get their
funding we're a young company lots of
potential no business model before the
1990s where did those companies raise
Capital where do you think they raise
Capital venture capital in general could
be Angel Investors they skipped that
process and went directly to public
markets nobody in public market had ever
seen something like this I still
remember the day in
1997 I don't remember the name of the
student but she put up her hand and she
said can we value this company called
amazon.com you know what amazon.com did
in 1997 there were an online book
retailer that's all they sold tiny
company lots of potential part of the
dotom boom and again stupidly I said
yes and I spent the next two weeks in
class and outside class Val amazon.com
and I kept a journal of every roadblock
I ran into because nothing came easily
it was like going to the dentist when
they found 50
cavities every input was like pulling
teeth but I persevered and I kept a
journal and by the time I was finished
valuing Amazon the journal was 74 pages
long I slapped a title on the journal I
never waste anything I
right I titled the journal the dark side
evaluation can amazon.com be valued
still on my website somewhere you can
download it but it became a book later
on but it's about how do you value young
companies with lots of
potential but no established business
model do we have a lot of those
companies around right now paler Airbnb
Uber I mean you can go through the last
decade every big name that you see out
there has been a company with lots of
potential did I forget remember to hit
the record button right let me make sure
lots of potential every time I value one
of these companies and I value mbb at
the time of its IPO zato the Indian food
delivery company at the time of its IPO
as I value the company I draw on what I
learned by valuing Amazon in
1997 and he moved forward another decade
it's it's 2008 you're in the middle of
another crisis this time caused by Banks
Behaving
Badly somebody in class again raises a
question why when Banks behave badly do
the rest of us feel the
pain company takes too much risk it
usually fails but when a bank takes too
much risk the rest of the world feels a
pain it's called systemic risk again I
hadn't thought through it fully but in
2009 there was no way you could avoid it
as you valued companies you to face up
the question of how does a systemic risk
player
valuation and then you get to the last
decade you get the decade of what I call
the numbers
company take Facebook I'm going to call
it Facebook I'm just can't get around to
calling it
meta I'm going to call Google Google not
alphabet let's take Facebook what's the
most impressive number about Facebook
you want to try what's the most
impressive number about Facebook the
number revie it's not revenues they all
companies with revenues far bigger its
margins are impressive but invidious are
even better the most impressive number
about Facebook is the number of people
on its
platforms there's three billion people
one out of every two adults on the face
of this Earth is on a Facebook platform
and I include Facebook Instagram
WhatsApp it's amazing three billion
people
most impressive number about Netflix is
not the number of bad shows that they
produce though they're kind of reaching
for the skies on that
one but the number of subscribers no
entertainment company in history has had
close to 300 million people paying $23 a
month or $20 a month every
month and I still remember again the Day
in
2017 somebody raises a question can we
value a
Netflix subscriber not can we value
Netflix I'd value Netflix as a company
said can we value a
subscriber can we help me out here
somebody help me value Netflix
subscriber you want to help don't worry
I I'll make you look really good by the
time this process is done to Val are you
a Netflix subscriber first okay how much
do you pay per
month that's the problem I have a 23.99
all my kids live off my subscription
sometimes I can't even get into my own
Netflix it says somebody's watching
Netflix I say who
where I've sent out multiple text get
off Netflix now I need to get on right
now so is anybody here pay for your own
Netflix okay lot of family subscriptions
okay good to know but you kind of know
how this business model works right you
subscribed to Netflix you pay a price a
monthly subscription but to value a
Netflix subscriber what do I need to
start with first in addition knowing how
you you pay what do we need how long a
subscriber will stay on as a subscriber
that's an interesting question is there
a statistic that these user based
companies report that I can use to
estimate that
number you know what a churn rate is
churn rate in subscription companies the
percentage of people who renew you know
what the renewal rate for Netflix
subscriptions is right it's like 95%
most people don't forget they have a
Netflix
subscription even if they don't use it
you get keep paying that
amount 95% churn rate translates into a
life of about 15 years I'm I'm I'm ready
to go now so 15E life what do I need
know I need to estimate how much
subscription Revenue Netflix will get
from you each year for the next 15 you
think that might go up every year you
don't pay for Netflix I trust me it is
it goes up every year in fact I read
this morning it's going up again okay
maybe at the inflation rate maybe at 5%
so I project our subscription revenues
I'm almost there what's the next thing I
need to I need to know whether there's
an expense that Netflix faces in
servicing a subscriber probably not much
they don't produce content specifically
for you so essentially there is a cost
it's a relatively small cost you
subtract that cost you now have the
income you're going to make every year
for the next 15 years that income is
very close to cash flow you discount
them back you come up with a valueable
subscriber in
2017 in response to that question can we
did this and I essentially came up with
the value of about $500 per
us subscriber you saying that's very
parochial of
you the reason I said us
subscriber I could ask this question but
since you don't pay for your Netflix you
probably don't know anybody from India
in this class don't worry I'm not going
to pick on you and ask you about a
history question at India you know what
Netflix costs in
India there's actually a iPhone version
that's I think $4 a month in which case
you can watch Netflix only in an iPhone
but for some Indians that's the only
streaming device you have you see why
this matters right a Netflix Indian
subscriber is worth less than a Netflix
US subscribe I'm not passing any moral
judgments it's just economically
you know what I find surprising is every
time Netflix has an earnings report and
you know one of the big things they said
look how many more subscribers we have I
keep waiting for analysts to ask the
question you know what the question
should be right you added 8 million
subscribers last year what's the
question you should expect them to
follow up
with where are they
right because it matters the value of a
US subscriber is
$500 the value of an Indian subscriber
in the iPhone is like $80 they're not
created equal I'm surprised that nobody
seems to ask that
question since we're on a subscription
based model after I valued Netflix I
valued
Spotify it's going public and it said
hey I've got the architecture to value a
subscriber how many of you have Spotify
I know you don't pay for it just you
know you listen to Spotify family
subscription all all that
stuff you know it's different about
Spotify it looks a lot like Netflix in
terms of structure right there's a
subscription there's a servicing cost
but what's the big difference between
Netflix and Spotify I didn't know this
until I took a deeper look at
Spotify when you listen to music on
Spotify unlike Netflix which where it's
a fixed cost the way Spotify pays for
music is by the number of streams that
get listened to
so who's your favorite don't you don't
have to be if you're embarrassed make
make up Taylor Swift that always works
cplay so if you like cplay and you
listen to Coldplay all day that's so
basically it's based on streams you see
what this does right when I sign an
additional subscriber and they listen to
music that content cost now becomes a
variable cost which means the value of a
Spotify subscriber is going to be worth
less than the value of a Netflix
subscriber because more of the costs are
attached to the subscribers that's a
good thing to know because it says look
you know when you increase subscriptions
not all companies are created
equal but that question triggered this
whole you know so so I valued an Amazon
Prime member I mean I couldn't stop
myself an Uber WR that was really
difficult you know
why how many of you Uber come
on don't tell me you use a parents
subscription there is no subscription
how does the Uber business model work
you download the app does Uber make any
money of you because you downloaded the
app now for them to make money you have
to hit the app the transaction based
model if you value me as an Uber Rider
I'm not worth much I use Uber probably
once a month only when I'm desperate
usually at 5:30 in the morning at New
York airport and none of the public
transportation is working my youngest
son is also on Uber he lives in New York
and I keep him allow him to use my
credit card because this is the only way
I know he's alive sometimes
right on some Saturday nights I see
eight or nine Uber transactions coming
through so what are you
doing I'm convinced he's got the Uber
driver lifting him from the bedroom
taking him into the bathroom and back an
Uber charge right basically he uses Uber
like it's going out of
style when youve value an Uber Rider you
can already see that valuing is going to
be more difficult because the smallest
users and the biggest users I can value
an average Uber Rider but there's going
to be a huge amount of Divergence not
all user based companies are created
equal and until you start to look at the
business model Amazon Prime is the most
fun right because there is this Prime
fee of
$139 a
year it's like a
subscription but you get what you in
return free
shipping partially free entertainment
through Amazon Prime 10% discount in
hold Foods I know all of this because I
live on Prime the one thing you can't
take away from
me but here's the thing when I had to
Value Amazon Prime that I discovered you
know that typical Amazon Prime member
spends three times more on Amazon than a
non-prime member as an incremental
Revenue why if I want to buy something
I'm going to Amazon
Prime I don't want to deal with the
Walmart front end of whatever their
online retailing looks
like it was tricky to Value but it was
fun to Value because it says look this
is what the Amazon Prime part of Amazon
is well so if you get a chance you go to
my blog you can see all of those but
essentially that those all came from
that one question in
class and then you get to 2020 it's May
March 6 I was right here
teaching exactly this class and
everybody gets a notification from the
University at the same
time we're all looking at our phones
including me you know what the
notification said right go home now it's
a week before spring break but take the
extra week off because there's this
virus floating around which might or
might not affect you but you know we
can't be around but we'll be back in two
weeks a complete lie but that's what
they told us we went home class
continued entirely online but for the
rest of the semester I didn't even come
back for the next year and a half
because we didn't have regular classes
until what well into
2021 what happened
Co the class went on and it was the
trickiest class I've ever taught because
I'll give you a lead and each of you is
going to have to pick a company to Value
you can pick whatever company you want
can pick fund companies companies you
always wanted to value and people in
that semester dead and then Co
hit I I was teaching my class on March
21st I think of that year with almost
the absolute bottom of the market
collapse around covid somebody in the
class says I'm desperate so what's
happening you get covid he says no I
pick Boeing to Value I said you should
be desperate that's worse than getting
covid because you remember Boeing in
March of 2020 was at the Tipping Point
what is Boeing doing to sell aircraft
right to whom nobody's flying the
airlines had grounded the aircraft would
Boeing had Deb the company looked like
it couldn't make it so I said you know
what your company is so challenging
let's do it in class on March 23rd I
actually valued boing in class there's a
YouTube video of it where I said look I
know the world is shut down but markets
go
on during covid we learned how to deal
with this immense upfront uncertainty
and make our best
judgments everything I know about
valuation I've learned in the course of
teaching this class so one of my
objectives over the next 28
sessions is I'm not going to give you
wisdom I'm going to give you a window
into thinking through questions because
you're going to face your own learning
processes as we go through so let's get
the logistics part of this class out of
the way okay my
office is on the ninth floor of KBC so
by now you're familiar there are three
buildings that are tied up there the
most confusing structure I've ever been
in my life it's easy for people to get
lost and sometimes it's a good thing for
me they keep looking for me for years
and they never find me 969 you'll find
me look long enough you'll get there and
of course you know I have you know my
when I have office I also set up a zoom
link but the people in the room will
always get first dips so if you can come
in do come in right just come in and say
hi second my email is my your primary
way of contacting me I get on average
500 emails a day I try to get them back
as soon as I can I'm usually pretty good
about responding but if you have a
question you need an answer that's
probably the quickest way to do it
there's a web page it's really my
homepage from which almost everything we
do in this class is going to be
structured I know there's this bright
space thing and I've seen and why you
come up with all these I've never used
any of their learning man M programs I
don't like them they like black boxes so
I will do what I'm supposed to do to not
get fired I'm supposed to put something
on black you know so I will do that but
everything that happens this class will
happen through my web
page know we there will be office hours
basically Monday and Wednesdays 12 to
1:15 I I would I teach three classes on
Monday and Wednesday I teach my
Corporate Finance MBA corporate finance
class 10:30 to 11:50 the NBA evaluation
class from 1:30 to to almost 3 250 and
then this class so back to back to back
so but I'm around and if need be I will
add a five to six when we get closer to
the quizzes so that you have a chance to
get to Kasha is here she is one of the
put up your hand Kasha she is
masterful she took the class last year
so she knows the ins and the outs she
knows how much I plan to torture you so
if you want a shoulder to cross on
she'll be it and um Elanor is also going
to be the other ta they are going to
have review sessions once every week
completely optional but basically they
I'm not I want I because I won't work
through practice problems in class
that's not my you know that's not what I
like doing it's not the best use of my
time but they will take past quizzes in
exams and work through practice the
mechanics and if you have questions
about valuing your company and where to
find
they're good resources to draw
on so here's what I'd like to start this
class with I call this the philosophical
basis from which everything we do in
this class flows what I'm going to say
over the next 25 30 or 30 minutes is
probably more important than all of the
technical details of how to come up with
the cost of capital or cash flow all the
other neat stuff that the rest of the
class
is there are the broad themes that
underly how I think about valuation
let's start with the first one I'm often
asked whether valuation is an
art or a
science let's start with the science but
is valuation a
science you're allowed to have an
opinion could be wrong I mean it's but
you're still allowed to have an opinion
what do you think is it a science let's
make it easy it's mathematics a science
it's the only pure science in fact
mathematicians are convinced that the
rest of us are
imposters so I have a followup on that
what is it about mathematics that makes
it a
science go
Ahad oh I can give you a lot of concrete
Finance stuff it's not just concrete
it's absolute I don't want to insult you
but what's 2+ 3 that's not a trick
question five left hand right hand
computer calculator North Pole South
Pole it's not maybe five it could be
five it might be five it is five if you
get any other answer you're wrong you
get the inputs right you get the output
right if you get the output wrong you
got you did something
wrong physics is mostly a science if we
all gathered together went up to the
11th floor managed to get one of those
windows open all jumped out at the same
time we don't fall in the order of our
IQs or where you are in the corporate
hierarchy the laws of gravity are the
laws of
gravity but the essence of a science you
get the inputs right you're going get
the output
right there is zero chance that
valuation can ever be a
science I valued inedia last
week I did my best why because I own inv
and have to decide do I get rid of the
biggest winner I have in my portfolio so
this is a momentous question to answer I
made my best judgments on on inputs and
came up with the value of 110 it's
trading at
140 it's take the
110 did I get the right answer do you
think 110 is the right
answer fact I'll tell you guarantee one
thing I'm going to be wrong 100% of the
time in what sense I've projected our
revenues earnings and cash flows for
NVIDIA for the next 10
years I'm going to be wrong because I am
not God in case you're working under
that presumption that you are God you
far bigger problems in this class I
would not suggest deal with that with a
therapist or something you see what
because you're trying to forecast the
future of course you're going to be
wrong valuation you can get every single
input right and still be hopelessly
wrong and it's okay I'm preparing you
for the pain that this class is going to
deliver to you because you want to value
your company how do I know I'm right
I'll tell you what you're 100% wrong and
it's okay
valuation is definitely not a science so
it must be an art right as I got off the
elevator I think on the third floor or
the fourth floor I noticed some a
Picasso hanging on the wall not a real
Picasso don't no NYU is not that rich
we're not
Harvard it's this fair you know picture
of a Picasso and I was reminded of when
I took my older son he's now 35 years
old when he was 8 years old to the Met
for a Picasso
exhibit you know how long 8-year-olds
last in a
museum not very long he lasted about 30
minutes with immense amounts of
bribery I'll get you take to the
baseball card store you can have an ice
cream as soon he lasted 30 minutes we
come out and ask him Ryan what did you
think about that exhibit he said dad I
was not impressed he said it was a
Picasso exhibit you know what he said he
said the guy can't get the nose in the
right place you notice this about
picassos the nose comes out of the side
of the head the top of the head the back
of the head it's almost like he was
either drugged or drunk which in the
case of Picasso he probably
both but for whatever reason we've come
together and we've decided Picasso is
special the nature of great art is you
cannot really teach it you can teach
about painting in the numbers or making
it look like it no nobody's paying $80
million for your paint in the numbers
your impressionist art I hope and pray
valuation is not an art because if it is
I wasted 40 years of my life trying to
teach something that cannot be
taught so if it's not a science and it's
not an art what the heck is it I'll give
you the word that I use to describe
valuation it's a
craft I'll give you the discipline that
I think is closest to valuation it is
cooking how do you master
cooking you could watch a Food Network
all day that's a good idea right Beat
Bobby F back to back to back amazing
amount of information you're going to
accumulate in theory you can tell me how
to make a sule but God help me if you
have to actually try to make a
sule you can read every cookbook ever
written but to learn cooking what do you
have to do you have to go into that room
in your apartment called the kitchen I
know you've been avoiding it like the
plague because you got door Dash
delivering every
day and you got to start cooking and the
first time you do it what happens fire
alarms go off disaster I still remember
the first time I scrambled eggs
nobody told me I was supposed to spray
the damn pan I scramble the eggs they
look really good they don't come off the
pan it was a non it was not a non-stick
pan pan and eggs go in the trash but I
learned a very important lesson about
scrambling eggs spray the
pan you learn cooking by cooking not
talking about cooking or watching other
people
cooking you learn
valuation by doing which means the 28th
session you're going to spend in the
classroom and not where you going to
learn valuation cuz you watch me talk
about
valuation you will learn valuation by
first valuing the company you pick for
this class you will learn more from that
than anything you do in the classroom
because you're going to face the real
world you have no choice I've never used
a case study in 40 years it's almost
absurd to me that we use case studies
you have 40,000 real companies out there
why do you make up an XYZ widget
company use a real company and you deal
with the real world on its own
terms one of the things I'm going to
prepare you for and it's coming is every
week I'm going to put up what I call a
valuation of the
week I'll value a
company I'll put it up there and then
I'm going to ask you to Value the same
company you're saying but it's week two
we haven't taken the class yet do what
you feel comfortable doing so what do
you think you'd like to value next week
Tesla Nvidia let's pick something
exciting I'll let me make the choice but
it be company that you feel is in the
news Tesla's always
fascinating because nobody's in idea
what kind of company is it an automobile
company an energy company an automated
driving company who
knows so I'm going to Value the company
I'll put it up with my story and my
valuation and then I'm going to ask you
to Value the company and the first week
next week when you do it my guess is
most of you are not going to feel
comfortable changing many of my end
purchasing I don't know enough you're
going to change probably the third
decimal on the risk free rate and leave
everything else untouch and say oh my
value is just like
yours I'm just going to let it go but
here's what's going to happen as we go
further because I'm going to pick
companies each week the week after I
might pick vinam milk to Value you know
what V milk does it's a Vietnamese Dairy
company he's saying what hey if all you
do is cook pasta every day you're going
to get really good at cooking pasta so
I'm going to give you different kinds of
companies I'm going to to give you my sh
at valuing it somewhere along the way I
might value the Washington commanders
you know they sold for $6 billion right
hey nice exercise to do especially if
they get into the Super Bowl give you
something to think about while you're
watching the Super Bowl what's that team
worth what's that team worth who's worth
more very different perspective and I'll
guarantee you here's what's going to
happen as we go further and further into
this class you're going to feel more and
more willing to disagree with
that's when I know the class is
working I know the class is working when
you come to me in week eight said
Revenue growth use for the company
absolutely wrong I'll let it go you give
me a I'm glad you're getting to because
that's the way we learn
valuation and the essence of a craft is
you never ever Master it take AI right
Garden Ramy Master Chef in a particular
quizy there is another quisine where
somebody else is going to be a Master
Chef the nature of a craft is you cannot
shut the door and say I know everything
there is to know about this craft I'm
done you've got to leave the door a
jar second big theme that this class is
going to I'm going to drive you
crazy by disagreeing or or taking issue
with you when you use the words value
and price as if they're interchangeable
we know what drives value it's cash
flows growth and risk it's always been
cash flows growth and risk of course you
can put a discounted cash flow model to
do it but that's what drives the value
of an asset you know what drives the
price of an asset demand and
Supply just what drives demand and
supply of course cash flows growth and
risk play a role but you know what else
affects demand and Supply it's mood it's
momentum it could even be Revenge
Revenge you guys heard of the GameStop
story have you guys been in a GameStop
many of you look too young to you this
used to be a right of passage for
teenagers until about 10 years ago you
went into a mall you hung out at a
GameStop store you played different
games and once in a while you actually
bought a game those days are done I mean
who goes and hangs out in malls anymore
right they're like funeral
homes so the GameStop business model is
broken and about four years ago the
stock price had dropped to about $12 it
looked like it was in its Verge towards
going out of
business when something strange happened
a group of people gathered together on
Reddit social media is not out of this
room or out of the markets it is part of
the markets now called Wall Street BS
and this group of people decided that
they were going to push up the price of
GameStop so you know what I actually did
this torture thing of getting on that
Reddit group to see what they were
saying to each other was mind
numbing cuz I was looking for maybe they
have a business story here that they can
give for why they think you know what
the primary force behind them wanting to
push the stock price upwards what were
they trying to
accomplish I'm sorry
what not NE because you troll GameStop
itself because GameStop loves it their
stock price go up right so they actually
like it so who's being hurt who are they
trying to
hurt the hedge
funds right the hedge funds that they
thought they were convinced that the
reason GameStop had dropped in pric was
because the hedge funds had sold short
which they had was the business model
the hedge funds that drove it down say
we're going to get revenge on you guys
by pushing up the price you know what
they push the price up to $400 per share
of course they along the way the hedge
funds came on their side they didn't
even notice that the hedge funds were
actually making money with them that
kind of Lo got lost but it was
Revenge mood momentum Revenge you
haven't seen any of those in your
Finance classes right but there's a
whole area of Finance called behavioral
finance and you know what it's trying to
do it's trying to explain why prices can
become different from value and stay
different and that's the reason I draw
this contrast when no I I don't do
valuation for a living I don't do
appraisals for money but once in a while
somebody calls me can you value my
company and they said do you want me to
value your company or do you want me to
price your company so what's the
difference to value a company I've got
to know what your business model is I'll
estimate cash flows and growth and risk
and value the company to price your
company I'm going to look at what other
people are paying for similar companies
it's a very different process
right when you see analyst Use multiples
PE ratios evab and comparable companies
or peer groups don't let them get away
using the word value for what they're
doing they're pricing a company nothing
good or bad about it just different and
can give you a very different number
than valuing that same company we're
going to spend a lot of this class
talking about valuing businesses but
we're also going to spend a chunk of
this stass talking about how best to
price companies you know why most of you
when you get out there whether you work
for an as an analyst or a banker you're
pricing companies you're not valuing
companies I don't even know why Bankers
use discounted cash flow models to be
quite honest your job is a pricing job
you're using the wrong
tool so I'll draw that contrast and
return to it over and
over say what are we going to Value just
about
everything I'm going to Value companies
that cut across the Spectrum right what
depend it doesn't matter what kind of
sector young or old what sector you're
in so we're going to Value Banks and
we're going to Value technology
companies we're going to Value startups
and declining companies I might even
value Bed Bath and Beyond why because I
feel the need for a
shower it's a depressing valuation to
do especially as it led up to its
bankruptcy we'll value every type of
company but we won't stop that not just
about public companies we value private
businesses I'd like to value that hot
dog stand the guy out there he's been
there 40 years I know him I know when he
had his kids where he went they went to
college private business is small or
large I even want to talk about valuing
or
pricing is one SoDo worth $745 million
as a Yankee fan I truly hope not but
that's just my Yankee fan speaking but
how would you
value a player to T let's take show
you're tany to the Dodgers you think
he's increased the value of the Dodgers
as a team I think he has by doing what
if it's value it's got to be cash flows
growth and risk right what does Otani
bring to the table that actually makes
the Dodgers a more valuable
team lots of merchandise and he's made
Japan an extension of the Los Angeles
Dodger Market there's a reason Sasaki
signed with I mean this it's if you
think about where if you think about
where most of the value for a sports
team comes from it no longer comes from
how many seats know whether you fill
your Stadium it comes from medeor
rights and the Dodgers have essentially
opened up a global media business with
Otani is Otani what's first otani's
contract is not 700 billion why is that
it looks I mean isn't that what the
agent said what's what's what about his
contract makes it
unique in fact he gets 680 million of
the 700 million in your 10 I he should
fire his agent because that contract in
dollar value terms is worth about 450 to
million the Deferred contract I think
he's worth well over half a
billion if you ask me does the same
thing happen when when one sort of the
Mets I don't see it I mean the Dominican
I mean where is he from Dominican
Republic or is it there's not we're not
talking about a big Market that you're
bringing in there it's not like you're
going to expand the market maybe might
help the Mets get to a World Series
which is a little
bump so why did they pay 745
million think pricing how do you decide
how much to pay for something you look
at what other people pay for similar
things right the minute Otani signed a
$700 million contract you knew this was
coming right cuz now now when teams have
to pay they you're not looking at value
added team what did other people pay for
similar players it's a pricing
game we're going to Value companies
we're going to Value business we're
going to Value assets we're going to
Value supports teams you'll ask how much
did Messi add the major league
soccer and to Apple's value you know why
right why is Messi affect Apple's
value because apple plus carries Major
League soft
ER they added about 10 million new
subscribers to the stream because of
messing so along this class we're going
to pretty much everything is a value
question and we're going to frame it and
reframe it so it's a class I mean the
way I describe this class by the end of
this class you should be able to value
or price just about anything so you go
for Thanksgiving and somebody says is
Bitcoin cheap at 109,000
I want you to be able to give a reason
answer rather
than it's worth whatever it
is so this is a class that covers the
whole Spectrum value and pricing it
looks at it through different
perspectives I'll value companies as an
investor we have very little role in how
the companies run but I'm also going to
talk about valuation from the inside out
if you're a private Equity investor you
can change the way a company's run what
would you
change so lots of different roles lots
of different as assets and the tools we
use are going to be relatively
simple it's my fourth
theme I'm going to ask a question it's
going to sound like a strange question
but humor me if I ask you to describe
yourself as a person would you more
naturally describe
yourself as a
Storyteller or a number cruncher what
comes more easily to you working with
numbers or telling stories think about
it for a moment you're saying how would
I know you've known for a very long time
I'll tell you what I knew I knew when I
was 12 years old after my first English
literature
class I was asked to read MBI dick and I
did I was a good kid came ready for the
discussion but 15 minutes in I noticed
nobody was talking about the whale put
up my hand said whenever we to talk
about the whale and I remember the
instructor saying there is no whale I
said what did I read the wrong book I
distinctly remember a big fish in this
book
it is a
metaphor my jaw dropped and it stayed
Dro for the rest of the class because
they saw hidden meanings and things I
didn't even know had a meaning in the
first place I came out of the class with
a singular conclusion I said never again
am I going to subject myself to this
kind of
and the rest of my school life
was laid out for me I avoided the
literature classes like the plague it
was algebra 1 Algebra 2 algebra 3 out of
school and these were the good old
days you went to college there was no
Core Curriculum crap where they made you
take a history class you know this this
little dance that we're going to round
out you it's a complete lie you know why
they make you take all those classes CU
if you didn't there would be no history
department so then you could just take
numbers classes you could get a numbers
degree go take a numbers job and you are
a numbers person for
life I was a numbers person that comes
more naturally to me so I want you to
think back what did you enjoy more your
literature class your history class your
algebra class cuz that's where the seeds
are s so how many of you are more
naturally numbers people okay how many
of you more naturally story
people I Noti some hands don't go up at
all so you're somewhere in the middle
you're confused you're confused people
so numbers and story people who do you
think has the upper hand in this class
numbers people or story
people you think evaluation what do you
think come on be honest with me when you
think valuation you probably expected me
to come in with an Excel
spreadsheet or if you've taken those
stupid training the street classes you
think I'm going to open an Excel
spreadsheet we're going to do you know
neat tricks like you hit these buttons
every alternate row will turn a
different color amazing that'll make
your valuation so much better right I
will not I promise you I will not open a
single Excel spreadsheet in any of these
classes but that's the view you have I'm
a numbers person this is a numbers class
valuation is All About
Numbers so I'm going to let you in on
what I think is the Dirty Little Secret
that nobody in valuation thinks about or
talks about evaluation can just can't be
just about numbers if all you have are
numbers on a spreadsheet you don't have
a evaluation you have a spreadsheet you
have a financial modeling much of
valuation has become Financial
modeling a good valuation is a bridge
between stories and numbers sounds
mysterious right but when I show you EV
valuation of my my valuation of
Tesla or my valuation of Nvidia and you
look at my revenues in your 10 let's
make Tesla revenues and you see 500
billion as my revenues in your 10 you
question you need to ask me is why 500
billion you know the answer you don't
what your is because I used to 15%
growth rate for the next 5 years and 6%
thereafter tells you absolutely
nothing the question really deserves an
answer of hey what will Tesla do that
will allow them to earn a half a
trillion in
revenues is that a lot of revenues half
a trillion what's the biggest automobile
company in the
world Volkswagen and Toyota it's about
300 billion I'm giving Tesla 500 billion
revenues already I am pushing the limits
of an automobile company which means my
story requires me to tell you other ways
in which Tesla can generate revenues
like what maybe automated driving maybe
software you're saying what's software
any of you own Teslas you own a
Tesla a lot of you seem to have family
ownership of Spotify which I think gu is
understandable you're young enough that
you know you know that Tesla without its
software it's just a tin trap waiting in
the garage right without it software it
becomes almost
useless right now the software gets
bundled in with the
car I can think of a world where you buy
a Tesla it comes with bundle software
but to get the upgrades for the new
software you might have to pay $200 a
year $500 a year that's a software
business model a different business
model you see where I'm going when I
give you 500 billion revenues it's my
job to kind of fill in the details say
this is where the additional revenues
are coming from every number in your
store in your valuation has to have a
story attached to it and every story you
tell me about a company has to have a
number that goes with it
like what you tell me your company is
great management what does that even
mean what do great managers do I'm
pushing you and I think it's good to
push because you can say this is what I
think great managers
do what makes Jensen
Wong CEO of inedia what why is he
regarding what has he done at inedia
that made I mean in addition the results
and the success how did Nvidia get to be
a $3.3 trillion company
it's a it's a chip semiconductor chip
company right oh first stop though is
does it make
chips it designs chips you know that
Invidia it designs chips you know who
makes all of the Invidia
chips Taiwan s conductors so it's a it's
a design company already a business
model that means you can have much
higher margins right you you're like a
software company you design somebody
else makes a chip they mark them up but
the reason Nvidia is where it is is over
the last 10 years is they've been able
to get into new markets before everybody
else first time this happened you can
say they got lucky happened with the
gaming Market where Nvidia and AMD got
there first then it happened with the
crypto Market remember Bitcoin and you
needed powerful computers Nvidia was
there first first time you're lucky
second time you're really lucky and then
the AI Market comes about and they do it
again and he said this isn't luck this
is something that's by Design
that's what great management at Nvidia
does so the way I would reflect that in
Nvidia is when there are big markets I
see in the future I'll let them get
ahead of
others it forces me to think about what
does it mean when you say great
management so every story you tell about
a company brand name about it's great
management about and if you throw busz
wordss at you I'm going to put them back
you say there's AI let's be specific
what exactly do you mean by saying AI is
good for you what does it do do for you
where does it show up so we're going to
talk about that link between stories and
numbers and I'm going to make it
explicit and the reason I'm going to
make it explicit is I have to be
explicit when I value companies because
as a number cruncher when I value
company what's my first instinct open a
spreadsheet be Off to the Races I've got
to slow the process down I force myself
to tell a story it's gotten easier over
time but I'll go through the process by
which I try to make sure the story gets
old which brings me to my fifth and
final
theme about 5 years into teaching this
class I think it was day in
1991 I woke up to a crisis a crisis of
Faith strange set of words to use in the
context of evaluation class right but
let me explain what I mean by a crisis
of faith I don't know about you but I
don't value companies because I'm
intellectually curious I don't lie why
it's I wonder what video is worth right
now maybe you do but I don't I have
other things to wonder
about I value companies for one reason
and one reason alone which is I want to
take advantage of those valuations and
make money I'm completely mercenary in
this process but to do that I need faith
faith in what in two things first faith
in my own value I told you I valued in
at 110 do I feel sure about the number
the word sure doesn't even enter the
Lexicon because I'm making judgment
calls along the way that's about what I
think it's worth but I have to have
enough faith that I can act on it and
second I have to have faith that the
price will adjust to Value remember you
don't make money by getting something
right the price has to come around you
know why I use the word faith because if
you ask me to prove that my Invidia
valuation is right I can't do it how do
I prove
it if they ask me to prove that if you
buy an undervalued stock that the price
will just to Value I can't prove it so
I'm going to give you the same answer
your priest or your Rabbi will give you
if you go up to and say this being
religious is a lot of work I'm all these
old sinning that I'm not able to
do can you give me some proof that God
exists you know what the answer is going
to be right I can't give but have
faith pisses you off but essentially
saying there's no proof I can't prove it
and I'm going to say the same thing here
you will want to see proof that all of
this is going to pay off I can't offer
that proof you will either acquire the
faith or you will not there's nothing
wrong with not having
faith but I can tell
you where my faith comes from I can tell
you when my faith is getting
tested and it gets tested every single
day you know when it gets tested when
the stock moves in the wrong direction
it's almost like God is knocking do you
have still do you still have faith how
about right
now and that's okay
we don't live in a world of absolutes
you can be okay questioning your faith
and I when I was growing up I remember
listening to Mother
Teresa I talk and I remember she started
talk saying every day I wake up and I
question the existence of
God he said Mother Teresa can get up
every morning and question the existence
of God I can wake up every morning in
question my valuation of Invidia you
know I can live with that this that's
why I've always had very little patience
with what happens in Omaha Nebraska
every year what happens in Omaha
Nebraska investing Woodstock right
people gather from around the world to
pay homage to a 93y old man they used to
be two 93 year old men but only one 93
talk about valuation I know I have great
respect for Warren buer but's human but
the proma has people think that they
have Absolut that they found the one
true way that they're the chosen ones
it's not a world of absolutes you're
going to be wrong sometimes you make
money sometimes you won't it's not in
your hands so we'll talk about faith and
I will talk about when my faith is
getting tested and I write about it all
the time when I make a mistake and say
this is where I think I got it wrong in
terms of structure we're going to start
for the next two sessions laying out the
big picture that intro slide so already
hit you with three emails maybe is it
three or four or whatever it is right so
we'll start with that intro sections
then we move on in the next 10 sessions
with the the inside details of valuation
cash flows and discount rates and growth
rates and betas and risk premiums and we
won't value single company fully during
those weeks because we want to get the
foundation right and then we'll spend
about four sessions with companies
valuing know young companies old
companies declining companies across the
Spectrum then following that we'll turn
to pricing companies what's the
difference how do we price companies
price earnings ratios EB to down
multiples all those different multiples
you run out there how do you use them
well how do you misuse
them we spend a session on valuing what
I call individual assets some of the
parts parts of a company what's
different why might you do that and
we'll spend a session on valuing
privately owned business what's separate
unique or different about valuing
privately owned
businesses we spent about four sessions
talking about option pricing in
valuation for the moment I'll leave it
there but there are times when you can
draw an option pricing models to Value
certain kinds of companies it's called
real
options Then followed that we'll talk
about what's different when you value an
acquisition in particular we'll talk
about the two words and Acquisitions
that keep coming up control and Synergy
what are they how do you value them and
how do you change the value of a company
so if you're running a company you're
brought in as a CEO of a company you
said double the value of the company
what are some of the levers you can use
session 28 we'll kind of look over the
whole class using your valuations as a
framework for looking over the class
because by then you would have turned in
the values for your companies so I'm
going to tell you what percentage of the
people in the class find their companies
undervalued overvalued the 10most
undervalued the 10 most overvalued and
you can compare yourself to every
semester I've taught this class so you
can see whether you're moving towards
more undervalued companies or more
overvalued
companies it's too late for this but I
did send you the reminder I mean there's
not a whole lot I Ask of your you in
terms of priors but there are three
basic skill sets that you should
probably bring in I will say some
terrible things about accountants in the
next few weeks and I won't take any of
that bad but I'll also tell you that
much of the raw information you get to
Value companies comes from where
accounting statement so if you don't
know the difference between gross income
operating income and net income and it's
not your fault it's your accountants
Professor was too busy talking about
debits and credits and need IFRS rules
that they forgot to talk about different
I would like you to revisit accounting I
have this condensed version of an
accounting class that I created just for
this where I talk about how do we use
accounting data in valuation and I break
every accounting Rule and I don't
care the second Big Tool Set is we live
in a world where we're surrounded by
data none of you is going to complain
that you can't find enough data you know
what you're going to complain about
there too much data it's pulling it in
different directions you know what the
discipline that was designed to deal
with that was
statistics again statistics classes
missed the point right they've they
essentially spent so much time in the
abstractions that this is a tool we need
in almost everything we do in business
so if you're again interested in kind of
brushing up there's a 12 session
statistic class and how to read a
regression not how to run a regression
none of us does that anymore because you
have tools that run regressions for you
but you use mini tab run a regression
what exactly does that tell you and
finally there are a few Basic Finance
tools if you're still struggling with
present value stop at some point in time
you've got to be in control of just
taking time value of money so there's a
foundations class that I've created
again with very specific pieces of
finance that I might draw on in this
class
class along the way I will torture you
every single day of the week for the
next six 15 plus weeks let me take that
back during spring break I will give you
s days
off and here's how it will go so this is
Wednesday we have the class today I will
skip this but at the end of your
Wednesday class you'll get what's called
a weekly challenge completely option
optional and what I will do is take the
Monday Wednesday class from that week
and create a challenge where I take what
you did in the class and take it next
step say can you expand on this can you
take it the next
step on
Thursday I'll send you an update about
where you in the project this is really
there are two ways to think about this
is like a GPS so there's this big
project that runs through the class what
this will tell you is this is where you
should be on the route knowing fully
well that none of some of you haven't
even started this is really to provoke
guilt you are really getting behind you
know we're getting to the destination
you haven't picked a company yet
sometimes it works sometimes it doesn't
so every Thursday I'll get send you a
reminder saying this is what you should
be doing this week on Friday I will do a
webcast on a completely practical
thing thing like no I want to get a
risk- free rate in Vietnamese Dong how
would I do it so I'm going to talk about
estimating risk rate in a currency a
little 20 minute YouTube video
on Saturday you'll get a newsletter he
say what
newsletter one of the problems when
you're in a class this big is it's easy
to get lost especially as you get to
week three week four week five in the
newsletter here what is this is the page
we're on our lecture notes you're saying
what lecture notes there is a lecture
note packet you can download it again in
case you completely lost it this is what
we did in the last week this is where
we're going and this is what you should
be doing so it's don't expect major
breaking news here it'll just be hey no
this is where you should be in the class
on Sunday I will send out a weekly
challenge I get send out the solution to
weekly challenge I sent on Wednesday
remember it was completely optional so
if you didn't do it don't check out the
solution what's the point of checking a
solution to something you didn't try but
if you tried it you can check the
solution again don't send me your answer
and say did I get the right answer this
is designed for you to start building
up Monday with class and I'll send an
email after the class saying this is
what we did in class but I said I was
there you were here physically but
sometimes you might leave
mentally you know you know what I'm
talking about right you get these
moments when you wake up and say what
happened in the last 63 minutes lots of
things so this will be a kind of this is
what we did in class today just in case
you left
mentally and on Tuesday I'll send you my
valuation of the week so the first
valuation of the week is going to come
out next Tuesday as I said I'm still
deciding whether to Value Tesla or
Invidia but you're going to see it every
Tuesday and this process is going to
repeat every
week in terms of class rules there are
very few I would like you to be here
even though I'm going to make it easy
for you to not be
here because every one of these classes
is going to be zoomed and recorded on
YouTube but if you choose not to be here
this is what I want to remember there
are
10,355 people taking this class class
with
you cuz the recordings I'm going to put
online I'm going to put all the material
for the class outline you know how much
they're paying as
tuition nothing if you're going to do
what they're doing you got to ask
yourself why am I paying what what's the
school charging like 15, every session
is like2 200 something dollars you don't
show up you know I think you know you
can there's some advantage to being here
physically so I'd like you to be there
even if you're 20 minutes late even if
you're hungry you want to bring a pizza
and eat it while you're watching I I
don't it doesn't bother me in the least
I have a very high threshold for
distraction okay your lecture notes will
come in three parts all three parts have
now been updated for the spring of
2025 you can download them in one of two
formats you can download them as a PDF
file the advantage of PDF is it trans
know you can in every platform it looks
the same or you can down download them
as a PowerPoint file and I'll add a
caveat the nice thing about the
PowerPoint file is it has the notes
section in it so you can check to see
the notes that go with each Slide the
downside is Microsoft Mac PowerPoint
doesn't play well with Microsoft PC
PowerPoint don't ask me what it's not
you know I have issues with Microsoft
this is one of those issues so when you
do the PowerPoint slides the PowerPoint
file is huge sometimes you can have
issues try it if you you know if it
works okay then all the more to you if
you do miss a class there's no excuse
for actually missing the material in the
class as I said by the end of the day
the recorded version of the class will
be available not just on bright bright
space and it'll be available as a
YouTube video because the advantage of
YouTube is you can watch it on an iPhone
you can watch it with with with low
bandwidth you can watch it with celles
service whereas know the stream that
comes from NYU you require know
broadband and bandwidth so I will conver
every session to YouTube video and um
you know and and all of the sessions as
we go through will show up on that link
that you see in the bottom so each
session you'll see the links to the
session the material used and as we roll
through you'll see all 28 sessions show
up there's no book required for this
class almost everything you need but if
you feel the need to have a book I have
five
and my first book Is invest value ation
the fourth edition came out don't buy it
it's obscenely
overpriced I actually refused to buy my
own book from John Wy saying are you
guys crazy who pays a $100 per book but
if you feel
rich or your parents feel
rich or you could use that four months
of Netflix subscription and buy if you
want to buy the book it's the only one
of these books that's a textbook it
comes
with if you can get the Third Edition
it's perfectly okay right it's much
cheaper if you can get an Indian Edition
pirated Edition I somebody sent me a
copy of an Edition in India where
somebody had taken the book Xerox to
every page they were selling it outside
a train station for like
$2 they thought I was going to be upset
I said that's a lot of
work so if you can go to an Indian Rail
train station and buy it for $2 or go
for it no so it's investment valuation
the second it's called demod evaluation
that's actually the very first book I
wrote in
1992 moment of ego I threw my name in
there in fact I asked the publisher
could we call it OJ Simpson on valuation
because that trial was going on that
would sell a lot more books they said no
no put your own name it's a practitioner
book about all the things practitioners
do then there's the Dark Side of
valuation about valuing difficult to
Value
companies young companies Troublesome
companies commodity
companies if I had to pick one book that
I would say is a book that really is
about the craft evaluation that would be
had it's a little book evaluation which
is really little it's 230 pages I took
the investment valuation book and said
how small can I make it's amazing how
much you can shed when you feel the need
to shed so you don't have much time the
little book and it's cheap you can get
for 12 1314 now on Amazon and about 7
years ago I wrote a book called
narrative in numbers about connecting
storage numbers something we talked
about as start the process I don't know
how how many of you have Apple devices
iPads or iPhones but if you go to the
App Store there's an app called U Val
which allows you to actually value a
company on that app so you can put in
the numbers like 12
comp it comes with the money back
guarantee you know why it's free so if
you don't like it St you got your money
back move on right but it's basically
just an app you can download you're
saying what if I have an Android it's
your problem not mine right you know how
much much work it is to even maintain an
apple every time Apple does a system
upgrade I mean we
spend we you know we have to hire some
computer tech guy to do it 25 hours 30
hours fixing this so it's some point
it's not going to be worth it but for
the moment it's still working the
website for the class and this is going
to be the central place to go will be
you know this is where you'll find
almost everything you need for the class
lecture notes know every single link is
there and the YouTube channel is where
all these lectures will go into one
playlist for this
class every email I send you because
there's going to be an email every day
last semester I had 136 emails over the
course of the
semester and I know what you're going to
tell me somewhere along the way so I did
not get that
email so here's what I'm going to do I'm
going to take every email and I'm going
to to put in what I call the email
Chronicles and you have no excuse you
can't say I didn't get that email it's
there you can go look it up on every day
so it's going to be a place you can go
to to check out the emails that have
been sent on the class
right wait there's
more Google Calendar for the class you
can check out when the quizzes are
there's my blog on which I talk about
pretty much whatever I feel like talking
about that week so I'm all over the
place there's a Twitter fee
and I'm looking for
numbers I'm at 420,000 I'd like to get
to a half a million so if you can get
your friends your relatives you have
multiple emails get them all
on and if you really have more time on
your hands and see how you could you go
to that link you'll see more readings on
pretty much everything we do it's close
off right I could tell you grades don't
matter but that's so insulting of course
they
do I would like you to focus on learning
but let's face it it's nice to get a
good grade as well truth and advertising
I'm going to grade this class like every
Finance CL class gets graded there's a
grading
distribution which is about 25 to 30 30%
A's and a minuses about 50 to 60% B's
and B minuses and there will be C's and
D's in the class you'll have to try to
get there but it can happen
right so I want that to be out there
that you know this is a big class 10%
C's and D's there's a lot of unhappy
people I will end up with I don't want
you to be in that
group but you got to try to get into
that group it really requires a lot of
work any questions before we end for the
deck so here's what I want you to think
about before you come back for the next
class next class we're going to talk
about a project it's going to be a group
project right so what I'd like you to do
is find at least three four or five five
other people in the class that you'd
like to create a group with in next
class I'll talk about what you're going
to do as a
group yeah good